hey what's up guys my name is the Cho
and I made a subreddit called The Cho
for um for all of you guys because
basically I was posting in uh rgame Dev
and r/ learn programming everything and
um well I don't know I just I felt like
I felt like there was enough interest in
this for to actually make um you know my
own subreddit now the reason I called it
the Cho and not like uh I don't know Cho
game programming or I don't know just
game programming or something um was
because I want this subreddit to be like
I guess a community of all of you guys
and me so instead of just having one
subr specifically for this game
programming series any other series I do
any any video that basically goes on my
YouTube channel anything that
um anything that that I do essentially
um I will post to this subreddit um well
you know not everything I do everything
that I do that I think that you guys
need to see so in other words it's not
going to be like my personal Twitter but
rather um I guess videos and stuff that
I publish now um I remember that a lot
of you guys uh you know way far back
wanted um wanted me to make like a
website with like a forum where you guys
could post um I guess your problems and
you know to really build a community and
have have someone to um you know to to
talk to and to be like you know this is
my game um check it out or whatever like
that um so that's what I really wanted
to do with this I really want to make
this like a community where you guys can
can talk to each other and um and hang
out and interact as well as well as you
know me being there as well so um I'll
be constantly monitoring this subreddit
obviously it's my subreddit I should
probably spend some time on it um so
anything you post here I will probably
see um once you uh once you find it um
I'm just going to open a
new thing
so once you um go to uh this you can
actually hit there's like a subscribe
button here which says um subscribe and
once you log in you know or create an
account if you don't have Reddit um you
can just hit subscribe and it will sort
of be on your homepage in up here in
your in your reddits and uh you'll be
able to sort of track that and see um
new posts by me and get notifications
and stuff like that um now I've got a
few rules over here and once you once
you do um sort of get onto this uh page
you can there's like this welcome post
that I made and you guys can read that
as well as um I guess you know the rules
and the basic information here now I I
have allowed anyone to actually post a
um a link so anyone can go over here and
submit a link and this doesn't really
necessarily have to be a link it can be
if you hit text you can actually just
type something like you know hello or
whatever you don't have to um actually
submit or anything you can just you can
just do this and anything you have to
say you know you can go ahead and say it
and we can really um uh interact as a
community and that's that's awesome uh
one more thing I wanted to mention was
the time when I plan on releasing a new
game programming videos now Australia
went uh Daylight Saving Time stuff so
time went forward the clock went forward
1 hour at that time uh that was
yesterday so uh essentially a lot of you
guys have been asking you know what time
does uh a new episode of game
programming come out now it yes it is
once a day um and no I can't make it
more than once the day I'm finishing
year 12 right now give me some time um
uh what you can actually do is you can
type in GMT here all right basically
it's coming out a 10: a.m. GMT so if I
just type in it's 24hour time if I just
type in GMT and uh 10 a.m. you guys can
can type something in like um I don't
know let's just say you live in Germany
so you can just type in like I don't
know berin or something whoops and um
it'll tell you in 24 hour time so that's
12:00 a.m. uh actually no that's 12:00
p.m. sorry my bad 00 would be 12:00 a.m.
um or you can type in something
like I don't know um well the people in
the US for example like Los Angeles or
something you can see that's 3:00 a.m.
um and I don't know United
Kingdom 11:00 a.m. all right so you guys
can see and then in Melbourne Australia
that would be uh 9:00 for me so 9:00
p.m. is when I release videos um so you
can use this time zone converter it's
just the timezone converter.com honestly
if you want to see exactly when um I
will release a new video based on the
game programming series because that
will be at the same time every day okay
so you guys can track that anyway I'll
um I'll see you guys later
bye